brought to you by msi computers msi
number one in gaming find out more at us
msi com we went right from the Last
Guardian to a completely new game yeah
folks at guerrilla games and this one I
feel like jumped immediately to my
frontrunner for a game of show I its
horizon zero dawn and just looks
fantastic yeah I got a crazy like
enslaved vibe of yeah slave nights the
host post-apocalypse lutely it's that
sort of nature the nature bound decay
like at nature has flourished the decay
is the bones of like long long ago and
you know you even get that vibe
reinforced by the sort of society of
humans that are more sort of a primitive
kind of a tribal look then and this is
the great reveal you at first like what
kind of weird animal is doing this scan
thing but then you realize she's not
hunting animals hunting machines yeah to
what end is it for like are they using
these materials and their compounds one
not Connie robots yeah yeah but you got
the compound bow she's got like the
weapons she's using the knife are
clearly kompot like made from parts
scrapped together but i think that they
ecoute the idea of an ecosystem here you
have these machines busted up oh yeah
that it's just so fascinating this
inversion of may of technology versus
nature and if there is I mean they
allude to a kind of story about how the
machines kind of left the human kind and
became like presses in a way cuz you
know she she seems to be preparing for a
larger machine invasion or like uprising
of a human's kind of species and it is
interesting they make such beautiful
eyes looking games and like yeah the
Killzone games for me I've always been
relatively mechanically uninteresting
like shadow fall actually probably the
most interesting I Killzone game I
thought yes I will play but what's
what's happening here with the like it's
almost like like crazy big boss fight
first of all it's a third person game
which gorilla that's completely new
ground for them then like this kind of
almost had like a sort of a monster
hunter vibe where you were like picking
apart different bits of the the monster
like yeah it looks so much more
interesting I'm so glad gorilla doing
something different because like
killzone like personally I voice think
Authority is kind of a mediocre
first-person shooter that that's always
looked amazing and I'm glad I want to
see that studio do something different
which they own and it looks so much
different from what they're going for
what they did before I mean they could
have you know played it safe and done a
new type of first-person shooter but
they did something completely different
which I am I'm kind of excited for and I
respect sorry for giving them the
opportunity to do that it looks looks
incredible looks stunning and there was
this moment when she kills one of the
and like the creatures early on she sort
of puts a knife in it and says sorry
little one have you so there's this
compassion for these creatures this kind
of like they're not just it's not a
terminator situation was like oh god the
machines you know it's like this is that
the dynamic there is fascinating I think
Danny your reference to enslaved earlier
on comes back around to sort of this uh
this connection to technology as
something that's not impersonal but yes
that we can have a connection with like
it's been there longer than they have
even you know it's like preak it's a
precursor to their problem civilization
the other thing I've got him from the
list locomotion was what was that game
we had the jet packs on your legs you're
running around 360 banquet wish I got a
real vanquish 5 off this is well ok and
a monster hunter and dragons dogma vibe
from enjoy these massive like and the
bow and arrow part of it but yeah it
looks it looks incredible that's horizon
zero dawn making a big splash at sony's
press conference here at e3 2015
Oh